[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
your work and your money i'm john
deloney joined
with my good friend joined by my good
friend best-selling author
relative hero to the office and to
america
america's career coach ken coleman how
are you man doc i am uh i'm living the
dream
and uh it's always fun when you and i
get together
because uh we we're talking about
everything all of it
we're not just taking money on we're not
just taking on you know
doing what you love and actually making
money we're talk we're taking on
relationship
stuff uh this type of stuff you talk
about on your show i hope we get a
couple of those calls today like i hope
i really do man i gotta have you on my
show to take calls
we need to but if you haven't if you
haven't
uh sampled the dr john deloney show whoa
get yourself a bucket of orville
redenbacher
and sit back and enjoy uh the healing
that is happening over there
i mean it's uh do you have a pg-13 and
an r-rated sticker that you put on those
shows we have talked about having just a
deloney after dark yeah here's the thing
though
i people are hurting man listen there's
judgment there the first few calls
uh first few shows james edited out i
would ask the per like why are you
calling me
yeah don't you have some friends don't
you have community
the number one response every time was
this i got nobody
yeah and reason people call you that's
right
people are lost man you know you and i
are basically in the same business we're
just talking a little bit different
focus you're from that mental and
emotional health
and then i'm coming at it from that
purpose everybody longs to make a
contribution
and you know there's we i talk about
professional purpose and you talk about
relational purpose if you really break
it down and it all works together
it all comes together so here's the deal
when john and i are together
we like to ring the bell to say hey if
you're listening right now
and and you feel like you've got some
nasty junk going on at work maybe some
poor leadership
some toxicity what do i do john and i
love to tag team those
uh we'll come at it from the
professional and the relational point of
view
uh you got some relationship questions
oh dr deloney is
he's he's on call he's ready to go and i
weigh in on those too
always you know i got an opinion yes
been married 23 years
parenting three kids i don't know what
i'm doing
i've never hey teens before it's like a
roller coaster without a seatbelt
you know what after my son was born um
after about two or three years you know
obviously my wife was the first dr
deloney she's a brilliant scholar and
we we spent a couple years with our son
and we
looked at each other more me than her
and i said
i think every other parent's an idiot we
are geniuses how
we have solved this and what we need to
do is quit our jobs yeah let's just go
teach people how to do this it's so easy
it's so easy then my daughter came along
oh and then we realized that we don't
know anything yeah no
i went through that phase when we had
three under three and i went golly
what a sleep and it's really hard but
man i pretty much got this down because
i could take the two littles
that are seven months apart we we
adopted and then got pregnant yeah and i
could take the littles
put them both down when they needed
their diaper changed and this was uh
i don't know if stacey's ever heard this
so i hope she's not listening but i
would wait until i saw both diapers be
full
okay and i would go okay now it's time i
would put both babies down
on their back yeah and do this number
here
could do the whole thing and i thought
i've got this and then
they started walking then they started
talking and i realized i'm nothing more
than a professional diaper changer
anything above me on that i'm a complete
blithering idiot you know when you'll
figure it out when you have grandkids
that's what i think i think you'll fully
understand
and that's why all grandparents see i
don't want to figure it out i'm looking
forward to torturing my own kids
with their kids uh i want to come over
to their house and say hey it's date
night go out
and stacey and i'll come over i'll load
the kids up with sugar yep
leave every light on their house leave
the doors wide open you guys want to
watch another movie yeah stuff
uh food wrappers in their couch uh in
the cushion cracks
yup i'm looking forward to enjoying hide
one or two shoes out of their closet
just around the house
so they go into their sock drawer and
steal one of every pair
and um just let it just take the phone
call when they call and say yeah
i think my kids are kleptomaniacs you
think i think you're right
so what we're here what we're saying is
is that uh the advice you get today on
this show is gonna be
worth what you pay for it that's right
and we're a mess yeah so it's okay if
you're a mess
and that's what this show is about
because we've all made messes
and so whether it's a work mess or
money mess or relationship mess uh
john we've done it oh man and there's no
shame in your game
that's what you and i love most about
what we get to do is hey
come on man it's okay i promise in most
cases you haven't messed it up worse
than i have
occasionally i take a call and think now
that's good
nick you overdid it well played man here
was the line you were way over
but but often man we were just walking
along side people hey you got some
exciting stuff coming are you allowed to
talk about that yet
uh i don't know where you're going with
this but i like i like that you're going
there
am i allowed to talk about what about
your big project it's about to
well yeah i can i can tease it we're
developing an assessment right now and
we've
we've written a big book that basically
the two things together are going to
help you discover what you were born to
do in your work
is it possible john that you were
created
to actually contribute to this world
through your work
i thought we were supposed to just sit
at home in cash
checks no see work is not this
utilitarian thing you do
to to make a paycheck to live we
actually believe i know you and i
believe this
and ramsey solutions believes that work
is a way that we can contribute
meaning we were given talent and we all
want to do something that matters to us
and when we figure out that that
in large part from a professional
purpose is work
now doesn't mean that you are your job
and it doesn't mean that your self-worth
is tied to your salary what it means is
that we all long to contribute
and we've been part of talent yes and we
want to work to contribute don't just
work for a paycheck
so we're working on an assessment that
is going to be able to
when you walk through it you're going to
come out knowing what you do best
what work you love to do most and the
results that you want to put in the
world i'm
jacked about that so one of the cool
things when you work at any
in any place right is somebody has a new
idea about a thing you know and you can
hear their idea and then people kind of
roll their eyes when they're not around
and they say oh yeah that's that's tom
again
there he goes he's got his idea and then
occasionally somebody's got an idea
they're working on a project they're
they're walking through something new
and there's a buzz about it
and so when ken's not in the room people
are talking
hey this like we're reading drafts of
this book it's incredible
this this is going to be a game changer
for folks who are stuck
or who think that the goal in life was a
paycheck or a salary or a title or a
thing oh yeah
um or i don't know what to do and i
don't have any path on how to get there
right well yeah yeah you're
foreshadowing the book which will come
out in november and i'm excited about
that it's
it's the guide up the mountain to that
professional pinnacle is it possible
to make the income you need and the
impact you want
the answer is yes just like there's
seven baby steps we have seven stages to
doing work
that you love that you were born to do
so that's coming out in november and uh
working on internally behind closed
doors is that it is that's very nice
outstanding it's very nice we're very
excited about it you know what else
we're excited about
taking your calls folks give us a shout
out eight two five five two two five
it's triple eight eight two five
five two two five life money your
relationships your work
all of it give us a shout we'll be right
back this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
it's triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to abby
out in wisconsin abby what's going on
hi uh thanks for taking my call
you got it what's up um i was just
looking into
i guess it's a career question um i went
to school for precision agriculture
so i had like a one-year degree and then
i have an associate's degree in
um egg business
and i really am passionate about going
to find a
career in precision agriculture it's
just really rough finding a job out here
for that right now i did have an
interview
a couple months back for a position for
that position
at a company and um then i never really
heard anything back from that they ended
up um choosing someone else i'm like i'm
not sure where to go from here what is
precision
agriculture i grew up around ag and i've
never heard that term
it is uh like the technology and the
equipment so
we're like dealing with the gis or gps
ah there you go okay um like variable
rate applications all that stuff there
you go
that's still above my head uh so so
they're driving tractors with gps
systems now there's
we're outsourcing farming now to
satellites and computers
okay and so you are you the person that
works on these machines when
these the technology when it breaks are
you developing new technology
um electrical like kind of diagnostics
helping install
the systems and basically just showing
people how to use them okay all right
and then tell me why
uh it is hard to find work out here is
what you said what does that mean what
are the factors
that's created a lot of the jobs that
there isn't really much available in my
area and then a lot of the jobs are like
kind of further away and i don't really
have the option to move
why because well i have my two-year-old
daughter here with my boyfriend and
so we don't we aren't really looking to
relocate
well okay so we hearing lies a problem
so the good news is is you know what you
want to do
and you know why you want to do it but
the challenge is you're going can
i i john can i don't know how to get
there well
what do i do next and so we're going to
have to start to prioritize unless i'm
missing something
unless i'm missing another factor so i
want to repeat this
the reason that um you aren't willing to
look in other places because you don't
want to relocate
correct yep and so you have a
limited option or limited options where
you live now
so that means you either get a day job
and the way i define a day job abby is
you're just doing something that's not a
dream job it's not even
necessarily on the path to what you want
to do which you've defined
it's that precision ag work so that's
one option is to get a day job
and keep connecting keep knocking on
doors
and and just be patient to wait for an
opportunity to open up in in wisconsin
where you are that's one option
the second option is is that you say all
right well just because there's nothing
here
and the thing i want to do is kind of
hard i'm just going to quit
and i'm going to be an old lady and i'm
going to be regretful that i didn't go
after that's one option
i don't like that option but that's an
option the third option is you sit down
with a boyfriend and go hey
this is what i want to do where did
where where does that fit into our
relationship we got
we got a child we're not married what's
our relationship
look like from a commitment standpoint
what about what does he want to do with
his life what's his professional purpose
you know your professional purpose and
we got to sit down and talk about that
and maybe just maybe we decide to get
uncomfortable
and move to where an opportunity is i
think those are your three options am i
missing something
no so why don't you want to move abby
i guess most of our family is like in
this area
so i've just kind of always
planned on staying in this area okay are
you willing to not do the work that you
really want to do
in exchange for being close to family
i'm kind of on the fence about it i
guess oh when anybody tells me on the
fence
i go you're not a defense you already
know you already know you just don't
want to admit it so why don't you go
ahead and just tell us
we won't tell anybody else
which way you truly leave i don't know
yeah you do yes you do
don't lie on this show i've always
wanted this position since i started
like
since i started the program and then you
know i graduated
a few years back and i've just been like
constantly
looking every so often to see if there's
anything available
abby why don't you tell us the why you
got it you gotta you gotta
train professional psychologist and dr
deloney you got me who's used to doing
these calls too
i can tell i know what the answer is but
you got to say it i'm not going to say
it for you
tell me the why why have you longed to
do this
because i'm past passionate about
helping like our farmers and
people in the agriculture world let's go
a level deeper why are you passionate
about helping farmers in the ag
community
because it's just important to me about
feeding our country and you know just
being able to bridge that gap between
like my generation and their generation
there you go i'm not going to push any
further but what i want i want you to
realize that i just did for you
so i want you to identify how important
this is to you
and your heart this is deeply connected
to who you are yes or no
yes so i'm going to ask you again are
you willing
to say pass i'm not going to go for that
i'm not going to do this thing that i've
longed to do
because i just want to be close to
family are you willing to say
pass what's the answer
yeah you are
you're willing to say nope i'm not going
to do this i'm just going to stay
and i'm going to just pick another path
and i'm going to stay near my family
i don't know
doc i kind of felt like
at first when i did get pregnant with my
daughter i've kind of felt like
i was like oh well you know this is this
is what i'm gonna do
all right you know what hold on so all
right i'm gonna get on right here
and then john can correct me and and uh
fix your emotions if i push you too hard
i want you to go with me for just 30
seconds give me an
example of an area that has more
precision ag jobs
give me an example in a state a city how
far away is it give me a quick example
there's a lot more in the southern part
of wisconsin and then there's like iowa
usually how far in that area of
iowa is that from where you are now give
me a give me a range
let's do a drive probably like four
hours four hours abby
you're willing to pass on what your
heart has been telling you you've wanted
to do for a long time because you don't
want to make a four-hour drive
you don't want to take your child four
hours away from its grandparents
really four hours
we're gonna pass on your passion yeah
you do know
you're just scared what are you scared
of yeah
yeah i know what are you scared of tell
us i really don't know i'm scared of the
unknown i guess there we go
that works so talk about the unknown how
old is your daughter abby
she's two okay so let's fast forward 18
years
and your daughter looks at you and says
i have this dream that i want to go help
people i want to help a lot of people
are you going to look at your daughter
across the kitchen table and say well
that's cute honey
but we do uh briskets on sundays
so i'll see you next sunday would you do
that to your daughter
probably not let's say 100 not
you wouldn't do that especially if you
said i'm gonna move a few hours down the
road and i'll still drag myself up here
think about your kids learn by watching
us
okay and so the example you can set for
your kid is
man you have dreams you want to be a
part of something bigger than you you
want to be a part of the agricultural
transformation of the united states
and i'm on the ground floor i'm one of
the few people who know how to do this i
grew up in ag i know those people and
other hearts and i know where this
thing's going
i can be a part of that transition or
we all just go to sonic after the game
and so that's what we're going to do for
the next 35 or 40 years
and let me tell you something abby if
you don't do this
and your excuse is family and it's an
excuse because you're afraid
you're going to end up presenting the
very people that you're trying to make
happy
i'm telling you don't get to the end of
your journey
and regret get to the end of your
journey and reminisce on the life the
adventure that you led
move abby you got to go this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five taking calls on money
life work that matters i'm john doloni
joined here by best-selling author ken
coleman
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to shane
in columbus ohio hey shane what's going
on man
oh not too much how are you guys doing
we're good brother how can we help
yeah so i guess the the question that i
have
is in regards to student loans and kind
of
how i should think about structuring my
life and that kind of thing
you went from student loans to how do i
structure my life
they got real tactical to existential
we'll do it we can go
go for it right so
i'm 31 i make
not quite 58 000 a year at the moment
and i have 165 000
in student loan debt whoa what'd you get
degrees in brother
architecture are you in the field
i i am i'm in the field um working
toward my license and that kind of thing
okay um how far away are you oh it's
two exams two exams what does your
income do when you
are fully licensed is it double is it
triple i guess it's kind of endless if
you open your own firm
that's that's a question that i've been
trying to figure out
um the answers vary wildly either
making what i make now or making
somewhere close to
90 or 100. okay
um are you clear you don't have to tell
us but are you
clear on what what must be true for you
to make 100
um i think so i
at least in the job that i have right
now if i were to make
that much or near that much i would end
up being in a project manager type role
and i'm not sure how long out that would
be maybe
five or six years if i had to guess yeah
here's the problem
uh we'll get to the money stuff in a
second but this is really important you
don't need to be thinking and you don't
need to be guessing
you need to be knowing and you need to
be doing do you understand what i'm
saying
i think so you have a hundred and
sixty-five
thousand dollars in student loan debt
yeah
so and you have and you have tur you
have a terrific education
and you're about your two tests away
from getting licenses that's going to
open up a lot
my point is you need to do more research
and know what the path looks like to be
a project manager in this current
company or know what it takes to make
100 somewhere else
you need to know that not guess not
think that's what i'm making sure you
understand
what are the multiple pathways for me to
make more money for me to get promoted
do you understand what i'm saying now
you need to know that
you can't just think about it you can't
guess we know how do we find that out
shane
we start talking to people that are
higher up the ladder than you are
they know because they've done it you
understand
yeah all right what is the fear you have
in finding out
the exact precise path or location or
destination
is there a part of you that looks at
that 165 and thinks
oh i may not have a path and it's better
just to not know why why
haven't you gone and just gotten the
brass tacks on the numbers and the path
here
so part of it has been um
i spent i spent a few years in a life
situation that was total garbage
okay um so there was that and then
i'm finally getting through that
um
so now it's a matter of i'm finally in a
place where i don't feel unstable all
the time
excellent so now i'm looking at the
future but i'm not sure if i'm
ready to take on the amount of
responsibility that would
get me the job that pays the 900
plus um that's what i'm saying it would
be
in a couple of years i don't feel that i
would be
in a position in my personal life
to take on that role at this time you're
being awfully cryptic
be a little more descriptive because
here's the thing you've boxed yourself
into a corner
with a hundred and sixty-five thousand
dollars in debt
right and so you got into a ring with a
big fighter already and now you're
trying to decide whether you want to
actually fight him or not
so in some ways that ship has sailed but
i do understand having seasons of my
life when i think i can't
handle or i can't stomach the amount of
responsibility it would take for xy
i get that but you're being kind of
cryptic
when you say i don't know if i'm ready
it's gonna be a couple of years are you
suffering from mental illness are you
dealing with a divorce like what are you
working through
um yeah there's there's mental illness
um and
just exp like having the experience
level like i'm not
confident that i would be able to take
it on okay
the job that i'm at now is bringing me
along and i am taking on more
um but it's the kind of situation where
the to go from where i'm at now
to the project manager position my
responsibility triples are quadruples
okay and at the particular firm you're
at right at the furlong map but also
just from you know colleagues that i
have and other
jobs that i've been at that seems to be
the standard is they're working all the
time
okay they have a lot of responsibility
they're
managing a ton of people and
i just don't
like i said my responsibility would
quadruple overnight
if i were to do that today for example
all right so that's fair yep
that's fair and and and so here's the
good news well let's talk
you know we'll walk you through how to
get out of debt and walk you through the
baby steps if you're not familiar with
it but but understand this
that whether or not you're ready and
let's just assume that i get where
you're going here you're not ready for
that it's going to take a little bit of
time to be able to earn that
responsibility i totally understand what
you're saying it makes total sense
so in the meantime we got to go do
something else we got to work a little
bit more get a second job because
we need to get out of this debt you're
31 years of age
and and you need to get out of this debt
as quickly as possible so the best way
to do that
is to increase your income because
obviously we're going to teach you how
to
cut cut cut uh your expenses rice and
beans and the whole nine yards okay
but raising that income is also
something that's going to allow this to
go faster
that's exactly right and here's the
thing i want you to remember two things
as
um ken walks you through this if your
boss if your supervisor comes to you and
says we think you're ready for more
very few bosses are that altruistic
are just going to give you something the
reason they would give that to you is
because they think you're qualified or
they think
that to be crass about it they think
you're going to make them more money
and so when somebody looks at me here's
a good example
when dave and i were discussing me
joining this team
one time we were talking about
negotiating salary negotiations all that
and i said dave you are asking me to
take a job
that i've never done i've never been on
the radio
and he looked at me and said i think you
can do it and i remember leaving
thinking
that sounds nuts number one but number
two he wouldn't
shoot a hole in his own ship just
because and so
that confidence got me into
radio school and practicing all those
things that we had to do to end up being
on the show does that make sense
yeah so when you are in your dark
seasons whatever your challenges are
when you're in those moments i want you
to remember your community to find your
calling they're going to be looking at
you saying hey
we think you're ready for this and that
often
is somebody lifting your arms up in the
desert man they are seeing things in you
you can't see and it's it's good like
indiana jones you go trust them you take
that next step in that next step
so go ahead and by the way it's like
parenting you're not ready for parenting
either it just happens
you just have to do it yeah you have to
do okay shane so assuming the only debt
you have is the 165 000 student loans is
that correct
um or do you have other debt yes okay
yeah all right so here's the deal baby
step one you're gonna put a thousand
dollars in a savings account that is
your emergency fund one thousand dollars
okay
and then baby step two is we take on the
debt and so let's say you've got three
different loans or two different loans
we're gonna start on the smallest debt
first and you're gonna attack it with
everything you got every extra nickel
we wanna get your budget as tight as
possible cut cut cut
sell everything you can sell get a
second job
third job whatever and you're gonna
attack that
smallest student loan and once you pay
that off everything you've been paying
into that you roll it over into the next
largest one and eventually
you're gonna pay all of those off and
then you're gonna move into baby step
three which is to put three to six
months of your expenses
in an emergency fund that gets you to
baby step four where you begin to put
fifteen percent of your income away
for retirement that's where you go hang
on the line we're also going to get you
the total money makeover
dave's best-selling book that will go
into further detail and walk you
through this journey thank you for
trusting us thanks for the call
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
delony joined
by my good friend ken coleman hey ken i
wanna talk about that last caller real
quick
um we had a young man who was 165 000
in student loan debt he is two exams
away from being a licensed architect
um making about 60 grand then life hit
him in the mouth
right he's struggling with some mental
health challenges he had some
relationship issues
and to make the money he's going to need
to make to pay the student loan office
in a reasonable time frame
he now understands whoa that's going to
be a lot more responsibility it's going
to be four times the workload it's 24 7
365 that kind of stuff
so it got me thinking about um
man i always wanted to be uh
an executive at a university that was a
job i was like
i'd plan that and so i built a world
around that and when i got the right
credentials i started working in these
ways until i started spending time
around executives and i remember the
moment when i thought
i don't want that life right i don't
want that job i want that life and it
was an existential crisis for me because
i'd spent
years sure money time all that investing
in this track and when i got close
enough to it i thought oh man
and then as i've worked with college
students law students especially they
get
one semester away from you know law
school and they say i
i don't want to practice law right or i
don't like this grind but i owe 150
grand what do i do
ken what do we tell people and i'm i'm
and this isn't a setup for the audience
i'm
i'm i'm wondering like what do you tell
somebody when they realize
oh man first thing i tell them is don't
feel guilty
be grateful now let me explain that
don't feel some sense of shame
or guilt like oh i didn't get it i
missed it
so i spent all this time and money
thinking i was going one direction
only to get there and realize i don't
want to do this there's so much guilt
and shame that people feel yeah
so let's first address that i would go
hey hey hey listen
it's okay yeah i'm i'm actually thrilled
you figured it out
now right as opposed to never figuring
it out or
figuring it out and denying it yes and
biting your lip
and spinning a life of tremendous misery
which affects your personal life affects
everything everything and by the way i
do what i do by the way it's like i
don't want people to just
be miserable in a career so the first
thing is don't feel guilt or shame
be grateful that you figured it out and
then go okay so that's the first thing
so
so there's that you were going to say
something i was going to say and
i reject the notion when people get
through with a degree and they go on to
do something else
that they say i quote unquote wasted all
of
not true you had to that's the very
thing i'm talking about okay so yeah you
had
this many professors think of that as
you have this many bosses this much
community you learned a lot it's in the
rearview mirror there you go i mean i
could sit there all day long and tell
you all the great things that you've
benefited from but
but that's the wrong narrative that's
why i'm saying no guilt no shame
be grateful that you figured it out now
in his situation let's take shane our
last caller
and and this was not his situation but
you're setting up a point that by the
way is very relevant
i get this call all the time on the ken
coleman show so i say look if you don't
want to go into architecture we'll just
use this example
great however if you got 165 000
in loans it might be a good idea to take
two or three years
and move forward move up the ladder in
architecture because you're
trained for that and it might be your
best opportunity
to make the money the big shovel that
dave ramsey talks about
to pay off the debt and we're only
talking about two to three years
and while you're doing that you might be
able to cash flow the qualifying process
for something else
and it and by the way let's not assume
that i got to go get another four-year
degree
exactly so let's just use a real-life
example let's say that that somebody
goes and does the architectural they got
165 000 in debt
and they go i don't want to be an
architect i'm miserable there's no way i
can do that well they can either
stay in architecture and pay off the
debt or they can go
well what do i really want to do and
let's just assume they figure out that
they want to go into technology
and instead of building and designing
buildings they want to design software
very similar parts of the brain by the
way right let's just assume that's what
they say they go okay
i want to be a programmer and design
software whatever
okay great so the first inclinations
they go well i'm gonna have to go get a
computer science degree which is running
about 160 180 thousand dollars can't do
that i'm already 165
000 debt what do i do well the ken
coleman show partners with bethel tech
which is just
one of a ton of options
bethel tech will train you me
anybody in nine months to go from zero
technology experience
to where you're qualified to start
making seventy five thousand dollars a
year with a path
quickly to six figures and more whether
it be a developer
or technology engineer whatever they can
do it nine month program
less than 15 grand that's just one
example of wait a second i can get out
of debt and cash flow
a bridge a transition to a new future so
that's what i always do is say
hey let's figure out where we want to go
and then we decide
which path we take to get out of debt
and the temptation is to sit in the ash
of what was and just be like well this
is it
blew it so i gotta stick with
architecture i'm sentencing myself to a
lifetime of misery for one bad decision
that's exactly right so first thing no
guilt no shame
let's be grateful that we figured it out
now let's get intentional
and stage one of my seven stages the
work you were born to do is get clear
let's get clear on what it is we want to
do
second stage is get qualified third
stage is get connected
and eventually we get started in stage
four so we may have to and i want to be
very realistic right now i don't want
this to sound
motivational oh it's just three stages
no that's hard work
and sometimes years right well it took
me seven years to get to ramsey
solutions and then three more
before i stepped into my dream job so
i'm at 10 years a decade
a decade to get to my dream job now in
this case it may take you two to three
years to get out of debt
and i would i would place uh i would
press pause rather
on the journey if that's what it took
because here's the deal it's going to be
worth it in the end
i may delay the transition
to what i really want to do two to three
years but what's the alternative
never doing it never and being stuck in
debt for 25 30 years of your life that's
right
or dying with debt so my wife has a uh
some friends and they tell a great story
they they were 35 and they were on a
date and
one of them said to the other you know
what i kind of kicked myself
i'm 35 i'd always want to go to law
school i mean uh med school yeah
to which the spouse replied i never told
you but i want to go to med school too
and they were telling somebody and they
said man we're not going to do that
we're not going to be out of school
until we're 42 and
that person wisely said this you're
going to be 42 either way
the only question you should be asking
is do you want to be 42 and a doctor or
42 and not a doctor
it's absolutely beautiful whoa we're
headed that way anyway
right absent a meteorite or a car wreck
so
man what if we just started walking that
away i was 33 when i realized that it
was not politics it was going to be
broadcasting but i didn't have a college
degree
and i didn't hardly know anybody and i
didn't have any experience and i had
three little kids under the age of three
that's my story yeah and 33 minutes
finishing my dissertation thinking i
don't think this is what i want to do
yeah and we're all in you know what that
means uh-oh i gotta go
take another class right another class
and here we go the whole thing and my
wife said um
think i want to stick around for another
right where i have to walk this whole
thing
it's hard sure it's hard but listen but
you're going to be 42 either way
yeah here's the deal once you figure out
that thing
and by the way there's multiple jobs and
career paths that are your that could be
your thing
that's what i teach no ken there's only
one thing what is the thing
no not just one thing just like there's
one dream person like titanic
no it's not true here's here's here and
by the way here's how you know as long
as you're using your talent
to do work you love to produce results
that matter deeply to you
ding ding ding that's a dream job so
there's a lot of things
a lot of things you can do so relax a
little bit yeah
do the hard work own it but for heaven's
sakes john i'm so glad you asked the
question because
there are so many men and women who feel
like they blew it
and they're stuck but they're choosing
you know stuck
is your choice everybody thinks that
well this happened to me i'm stuck
uh i'm not questioning what happened to
you
uh but you're choosing to be stuck
you really are because i've gotten my
car stuck before on the beach
i've got my car stuck in the snow back
to fact this last snow we got nashville
and i could have just sat there and went
well stacy i'm stuck
gonna have to sit here until the snow
melts or until somebody comes along this
deserted area of the beach and digs me
out
no i got my butt out of the freaking car
and i got down on my hands and knees and
dug out gloves because i'm an idiot
and dug myself out cause it's the
rockies because being stuck
is your choice and getting unstuck is
also your choice
ugly action well thanks for talking
through that with me
man my heart's with shane
make some good choices good folks and be
kind to one another
stay tuned that's in one hour in the
books we'll be right back this is the
ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
your work and your money i'm john
delonie joined here by best-selling
author and ramsey personality ken
coleman and we are taking your calls on
just about
anything your relationships your work
bosses that you're struggling with
where to go next in your in in your
parenting in your kid's schooling
in your career whatever is coming down
the pipe and we're also going to take
your calls on money
and we can figure it out along the way
ken how we doing good good good we
always have fun together that's right we
got the doctor
and the guy who wishes he was a dog
but not good enough of a student to do
it so i i learned early on
you can sprint a marathon or you can
walk it it's the same
it's all good or just read about what
it's like to do a marathon that's
even better you can watch one on
television yeah and scroll right back
that's right so give us a call at
825-5225
kelly's standing by to take your calls
let's go out to charles in orlando
florida hey charles what's going on man
hey uh good day thank y'all for the
laugh there
what's up man i my wife uh
passed away
about 10 days ago and uh
and i'm just trying to find the next
steps
of what to do we do have a life
insurance policy and
uh um i'm just trying to figure out what
steps to take different
you know to make sure that i i don't do
anything too fast and
uh just take my time and make good
decisions
charles i'm so sorry yeah i'm so sorry
tell me about your wife man
oh the best absolutely we had uh
we had over 200 around 200 folks at her
reception after her funeral
and uh just uh absolutely
everybody i wish i had kept up with the
number of ladies who wrote me
and said that she was her best friend
wow what a testament so you told me
about some numbers
i want you to tell me about her
she is extraordinarily loving
she was uh always encouraging
a wonderful christian mother wife and
grandmother
and uh just an extreme extreme
encourager for everyone
oh wow how many years were you married
uh
46 56.
was it unexpected or something that was
a longer journey of health issues
she she contracted leukemia back in 2015
went through one round of chemo and went
into remission for
five five plus years and then it cleared
back up
and uh just got a lot more aggressive
than we were expecting and
she she'd been sick about two and a half
months
uh at the time she passed away wow well
charles
first man our hearts are with you
brother yeah yeah thank you so much ken
and i have been married a long time and
um i just i appreciate you honoring us
and with with your trust and
thank you so much um the second thing
here is do you have any kids
uh yes got got two kids uh they both
live out of town
how they doing they're they're doing all
right too
uh just the uh uh
my son left just today just a few hours
ago to go back home
after being here for about 10 days okay
so um in the in the normal arc of grief
right um i always make a
a little star on my calendar when i've
got a friend of mine who's going through
something
um for 10 days to about
two months after something like this
when the last guy leaves like your son
did today
this is when your house gets real quiet
right yep
this is when this thing starts to get
real real real
right and that's when you look at the
pile of bills and the questions and the
what nows and
um that's when stuff it's been heavy and
it's been messy
now it takes on flesh and bone right
so the first thing i want you to
recognize is there is no rush
okay right your bills are covered y'all
are okay financially
yes okay all right so um
the guy who trained me in crisis
response and actually walked me through
some stuff that i was dealing with
said no decisions for six months after
something gets sideways
okay okay um and i make sure that i've
got somebody with me when i'm making big
decisions
in the middle of grief okay
do you have a buddy that you can call
you can reach out to
i do okay so i would have somebody come
over
and help you and it will also somebody
when they love you and they don't know
what to do this helps give them
something to do with their busy schedule
i mean with their with their busy hands
right um so you're
in a weird way you're giving them a gift
too and coming over and saying hey we
got to dig through all this stuff
i'm not ready to go into the closet i'm
not ready to
fill in the blank but we gotta start
sorting through some stuff
all right and you gotta let one or two
or three guys know in your life
i may call you at two in the morning and
i need you to bring a box of cereal
and some cheeseburgers and a beer and
come over right
and those three guys man you will give
them a gift
and they will grumble and like guys are
but man it will give them a purpose to
get up and show up and come over to your
house
okay you can't do this by yourself what
i'm telling you right
right so practically speaking you got a
life insurance policy
what what other um
what other things exist out there well
we
we are other than our house we're
debt-free okay
and uh the uh
i'm i was kind of in a transition from a
work standpoint
uh i've been because i've been a
consultant for just over 10 years
and i made reasonable money and uh
but it's also something that it started
to wear on me and
i was i was trying to think of what else
i could do because
even though i'm now on social security
uh that's
certainly not enough money to live the
kind of life i want to live
and so i was i was in transition of
possibly changing jobs
before this happened okay and uh
now of course you know there's 12
you know without without the wife
things is uh there's even more
possibilities that
that could open up that's right so so
listen
there's gonna there's gonna toggle back
and forth between
i can do anything i can move i can go be
my grandkids
and it will toggle back to that amount
of untethered freedom
will feel like you are falling and there
is no one to catch you okay
right so here's the important thing you
cannot judge your grief
it's gonna be what it is you're gonna
have
up days and down days that's why having
people with you is really important
get the um life insurance stuff carried
out put it in a money market account and
let it sit for six months and don't move
don't run don't go running start a new
job or quit your job
be slow be methodical we'll be thinking
about it and praying for you and
charles i would just say take the six
months and call me call the ken coleman
six months from now with those ideas
about transition
it will definitely get you lined up but
i do think you take six months and dream
a little bit get healthy have some fun
do all the things john said
then call me
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
auto insurance companies love to play
the game where they see
just how high they can jack up your
rates for no reason
great game huh good news is it's not
hard to beat them at their own game
all you have to do is check up on your
policy every year or two to make sure
you're getting the best
price for your coverage that's it and
what's even easier
not to mention free is that you can hire
one of our endorsed local provider or
elp
insurance agents to do this for you elps
are independent agents who shop to find
you the best coverage free of charge
they don't work for one insurance
company meaning they have the freedom to
shop as many
policies as it takes to find the one
that's right for you
don't sit back while your insurance
company raises your rates for no
reason just to see if they can get more
money out of you
text auto to 33789 and put a trusted elp
agent
on your team that's auto to 33789
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll
save even more use promo code ramsey to
get the best
deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from emerald in
kentucky
emerald writes i was taught your
financial principles in high school
i come from a poor family and i've
worked since i was 17.
i'm currently 28 years old debt free own
my own home and have my dream
car too i've never been married because
my relationships never last long enough
i feel stuck and don't know what my next
move should be
i have the means and the time to retire
young but i lack the path for it
what can i do when it's all on me to
make these decisions uh
i i gotta tell you it irritates me when
we get
this onion in a written question i know
there's a lot here there's about four or
five questions
that i would need to adequately ask and
answer this but
uh we'll tag team this one uh i'll
address the i lack the path for it
you don't lack a path for retirement you
lack a purpose
in your work uh you you're not quite
sure what you want to be when you grow
up
or and again we don't have him on the
phone uh
but you're not clear enough to be
confident to say
this is what i want to do and when you
can when you can
you can identify the mountaintop to use
a simple analogy for everybody
when i know that's the mountain i want
to climb well now i can
go train and i can go talk to people
who've done it i can go hire a guide i
can go buy the equipment that will allow
me to get up the mountain yeah but when
i don't know what mountain i want to
climb i'm just kind of just standing
down in the valley oh there's a mountain
range there's one
and boy that can cause a lot of
confusion so i'll address that piece
right there
knowing where you want to go is what you
might
it doesn't matter where you are if you
got a map if you don't know where you
want to go you still feel lost and you
got a map in front of you that's right
that's what i hear in this so
i think emerald does a great job in this
in this
small little paragraph that he sent us
in describing the futility
of how some people interpret the
american dream
which is get a house
get your dream car that's right don't
owe anybody any money
and all of your so problems yes they're
a vapor they go away
yeah and if you have no one to
share your life with if you don't have
relationships
none of that crap none of it dude this
is what this is what you and i do you
can have
nothing but you got a gang to walk with
you and
life works you have purpose in two major
areas of your life folks
and this is what doc just addressed
relational purpose first and foremost
we're we are created as humans to
connect period
okay secondly we are created as humans
to contribute
yeah and that's work relationships
connection
work contribution i'm just telling you
and then
wait on that list buying crap yeah so
but here's the point he's got it
he's debt free good on him 28 years of
age uh
got his got his home good on him he's
got his dream car
and he's stuck it's what he says right
here i feel stuck
well he's not stuck he's
lacking he's untethered he's lacking
purpose in his
connection he's lacking purpose
in his work that's contribution yeah
come on folks and he over
he did uh emerald's probably an awesome
awesome person
oh he's no question overcame a poor
family yeah that's all
i i don't want to live this life i'm
gonna i'm gonna discipline work hard
yeah hard yeah absolutely so here's what
you do
you go submit to other people come on
you go say
hey man you wanna go hang out yeah and
you think
it's hard to make a make a to win a deal
you think it's hard to grind out uh
paying off your home
it's real hard to to be vulnerable and
yeah say hey you would go hang out
because they might say no and reject you
hey i want you to call doc
here on the dr john dolone show and say
hey man none of my relationships last
very long and then just let john
dig that's the issue that's right why
that's right and here's the deal john i
don't know what's behind this but i do
know this
at some point you got to choose to love
somebody yep
and harder you got to choose to let
other people love you oh
that's hard oh i thought i said
something good and you just went trump
that was really good dude i'm serious
that was really
mirror it's exactly right maybe he's not
loving himself enough to be loved
of course not because at some point you
look across the table and you say why in
the world would this person spend time
with me yeah
because i know what's going on in my
head i know what i think about other
people and how i judge other people i
know i get pissed off and frustrated and
fill in the blank all of my failures
john uh here i host a show helping
people discover what they're supposed to
do professionally that
that contribution that purpose and and i
find out all the time john
that we should be doing our show
together some days cause it's like
you'll dig into a situation like this
you know why he hasn't figured out what
he wants to do professionally
because maybe he's been
hurt deeply by somebody yeah and the
very thing
that is keeping him from lasting in
relationships
not loving himself and accepting love
may have something to do with why he
can't figure out what he wants to do
with his life
it's all connected is the point i'm
making absolutely and when you
are in fight or flight oh here's what's
beautiful about
the world we live in brother you can
fight and run
yes and make a ton of money yo you can
fight and run and be real busy work 24 7
365 throw book deals
at you pay you big money because your
whole story is i'm a fighter man
and i can run i can out busy anybody and
what do we call it
man he's got a great work ethic success
crushes it
right he's a boss and he's completely
alone
right total mess so what i'll tell you
is i know a number of
here's how big relationships are to me i
don't think i've ever told us on this
show oh this is
when i was uh interviewing here
dave was showing me around all this cool
stuff and i mean it's it's
enticing it's exciting i asked dave who
do you listen to
who do you hang out with well he
obviously said me but who else
he said number one first and foremost
can't call me host of the ken coleman
show
but he rattled off a group of people
that his eagles group
listens to yeah who call him and say hey
why'd you say that right who
speak into his life and that i remember
leaving here thinking
dave and i are going to disagree on a
lot of things but i trust him yep
because he's got people who
speak into his life no question and why
do all of this
why get your dream car if you get known
to riding it with you right
right why exactly what's the whole point
of having a house
when you don't even use but one or two
rooms
listen um i didn't mean to spend this
much time on blinds.com question but
listen they're getting their money out
of this
segment if you were listening to this
show that's
at the end of the day if people at your
funeral
talk about what kind of car you drove
they talk about you know
their lies tom he had a giant house
yeah or they talk about wow he really uh
had a cool job yeah
man what you want people at your funeral
to talk about
is man he showed up he was hilarious
we spent years together it's true we
were married
like the last caller for 47 years and
everyone thought they was they were her
best friend right
your legacy is the connection those
people had with you they
talked about the connection and the
contribution you made in your life
into their life they all thought they
also were best friends the people that
you touched
so good it's about relationships good
folks
[Music]
do not do life alone this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is
the ramsey show taking your calls on
life and work
and purpose and money let's go to shelby
in dallas texas hey shelby what's going
on
hey how are you guys doing today
outstanding how are you
wow doing well very cool so what's up is
about
um how to teach our kids the value of
money
um a little background on us where my
husband and i are in our mid-thirties
we've got three kids under four so we're
starting young
debt-free other than our home wow wait
we paid off in a couple years
and thanks to dave and chris we are
everyday millionaires working on
being multi-millionaires wow very cool
congratulations guys we've done thank
you thank you thank you all
we've done most of this journey without
our kids seeing it so i kind of have a
two-part question
first of all how do we teach them a
foundation of
gratitude and appreciation starting with
toys and birthday gifts and vacations
now and then later on
we're blessed in a position to pay for
cars in college
and then kind of part two of that is how
open are we with our finances our
salaries our budget meetings
and things like that well you'll take on
the easiest one first that's the second
part of that question i'd be
i'd be open to the point if they don't
need to know your salary and stuff like
that because kids can't be trusted with
that information they go to school and
they just think they're talking their
friend they're like hey my dad makes
this much
so i would i would not uh reveal how
much you all make but as far as
uh having your budget meetings in front
of them they see you guys at the kitchen
table or wherever your spot is
uh talk to them about line items and
what the budget is made of
so instructing uh through transparency i
think that that's a good place right
there i'd be very open about budget and
how you don't do debt and all that kind
of stuff
i just wouldn't share how much you all
make i actually um
shelby i asked dave that question oh you
did um
off air how do i walk like i always want
my kids involved in these conversations
i want my son to see these numbers
and that's exact same wisdom there right
which like i don't tell the kids
our salary but i want them to know
here's how much that light bill in
dallas texas cost it's expensive
oh yeah um i openly gripe when i have to
go into the emergency fund and fix the
car
i want him to hear that that's right i'm
like oh man
so hey shelby one thing that i love and
i may be a slightly sadistic parent i
love it when we're gonna do our budget
meeting
and i tell my son hey you gotta come sit
at the table and listen
and he goes i kind of love that
right and i don't do it every time what
age do you start
at that i don't think are there really
too little
yeah i mean one two and four is too
little
right yeah um yeah but what you want to
do is
think of the words you use think of
they're picking up your
your bot they're absorbing you they're
picking up your body language and so
if every month you all sit down to do a
budget and y'all are yelling and
fighting
and you're like rolling your eyes at
each other your kids will understand
that
money is a thing to avoid it causes
relational conflict
if it is not silly and absurd but if you
all say hey we're gonna have our budget
meeting and you and you say those words
out loud then you'll sit down at a table
and you all are prepared and you're
planning
and the kids are playing in the floor
below you they begin to absorb that
that this is a natural rhythm of a
family this is what people do
every month they plan and i would
announce it to your kids
this is budget meeting time and so you
all are going to play on the floor where
mom and dad talk about
how much money we made how much things
cost how much we're going to save
how much we're going to give and you
just begin to teach them that language
and it doesn't become a
the birds and the bees talk is much
better when it is a part of your daily
interactions with your kids
and not when it's some weird event they
remember the event
right yeah i'm uncomfortable already
thinking about it i've had to do it i've
had to do it three times
uh shelby i'd say this i think the
five-year-old i i think once that
four-year-old becomes a five-year-old
kindergarten age
there's no magic age here this isn't a
rule but i think you could start the
conversation about chores
absolutely start paying them a buck a
week or two bucks a week or whatever
that's right
uh they're they're gonna begin to be to
see a really natural relationship with
money
when i put forth effort in other words
work i get compensated
and that's a wonderful little tool
before they ever understand budgets is
just
hey here's the deal and we i think we
still sell them here at ramsey solutions
but we have them
uh we're selling them three or four
years ago at least but my kids still
have
um the uh the p banks the piggy banks
that we sell at ramsey solutions with
the little
red rubber tops and and it's spin and
and
and save and and and you know here's the
deal like they've learned to tithe
and and they kind of get this whole
conversation just really natural as john
said so i think
from that standpoint showing them the
value of work
uh and making them earn stuff uh i think
is huge i mean
to this day josie is 12. and uh
i don't know if your daughter's into
this little josephine but these uh
these uh fidget things there's all kinds
of these little
puppets and they're [ __ ] around these
things and they're really popular with
sixth grade girls apparently
and so she wanted to buy several and i
was like babe
i'm not going to keep i mean you've got
five you want 15.
go buy them so you know what she showed
up the other night and she said hey mom
what can i do what can i do what can i
do
and josie's motivated and i told her i
said i'm proud of you she created a
checklist for a week
and she cut a deal with us we'll pay you
this much i'm happy to do that
that's fantastic so shelby um
i'm i'm getting into ken's territory
here but here's a cool thing that
happens when you start teaching kids
about
work and monetary rewards
is it's a great time to talk about their
role
in the family yeah their purpose what
they contribute
they begin to learn deep in their soul
this family runs does not run without me
i'm a part of this thing
and so what we did with our kids is we
broke up here's a few jobs that we do in
our house that you don't get paid for
it's part of that's right all of us are
together on this
and then i mean you gotta go get on the
riding mower and mow momo i'm gonna pay
you for that because that stinks
paying you to clean up your room no
that's a part of being a human being
inside the delony house right
and so um one other thing you talked
about gratitude
my wife is is the one that really drove
this home teaching our kids
when they get gifts they don't play with
them until there is
a thank you card written and that's good
they go through an entire dramatic
process and the
the writing is awful sometimes it looks
like it was written with somebody's feet
right it's not
great it's it's about the exercise
um and we thought that counts and right
the correlation i made
right and another thing that we do she
then again this is my wife's
they created um bags of food that stay
in the car
that we can pass out when folks uh are
on the side of the road
and they need money or help and here's
what we're trying to do we're trying to
teach our kids
that the life they're growing up in is
not everybody's life
in fact it's very few people's life and
you got to walk through life with your
eyes
wide open for people you can serve and
you can help and be a part of it's about
gratitude
so your wife and my wife dude we've
really outmarried ourselves there's no
question about
it two things that i'll share with you
that stacey did shelby
and we learned this from a marriage
mentor a couple that
mayor excuse me mentored us early on and
they did this
with their kids we stopped doing this by
the way when the kids got to sixth grade
because of the type of parties
but for each of our three kids birthday
parties starting at the age of three
we would invite their friends over and
their their
presence the the kids present was
a really awesome party and we told all
the parents
don't send gifts with your kid they're
like what
these adults send gifts you come
and you bring food you bring
clothing you bring a toy and so all
three coleman kids
their birthday party was an awesome
bounce house or some cool experience
that was the gift they didn't get toys
from us
they didn't get toys from their friends
because in today's world you do
you do a birthday party for your
five-year-old it's like christmas like
this
toys r us 15 kids show up and every
parent's trying to outdo the other
parent
and so we learned this so what we said
was and people it took them a while
a couple people tried to sneak a gift
and please take it back
and so then and so each of our three
kids shelby would then take
everything that was brought and they
would take it to a children's hospital
if it was toys
they'd take it to a food shelter if it
was food that was really really a
beautiful thing and our kids learned
that the party
the relationships the friends that was
your guest that's the magic right not a
toy
so at the end of the day if you distill
all the things that ken and i just said
down into one word it's intentionality
you can't screw up
intentionality with your kids right be
present with them
think through it let them see your
budget let them
see the the fun and the smiles and the
frustrations with budgets make them be
grateful teach him gratitude i just
can't make him be grateful teach him
[Music]
gratitude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
this is the ramsay show aaa 825 5225
let's go out to jacob in my old hometown
of abilene texas hey jacob what's going
on
man hey how's it going we're doing great
how about you
i'm doing good i'm blessed thank you
outstanding brother how can we help
so i'm 28 years old i'm recently
divorced
i have a custody of my my oldest
we live in an rv right now i just sold a
45 000
truck yesterday which brings my debt
down to 21 000
okay so i'm without a vehicle i do have
a work truck
um i'm clearing over 120 000 a year in
the oil and gas industry
okay so um my question is do i just
start making minimum payments on my debt
or do i go and try to get me a 15 000
trust financed to help me with my lawn
care business on the side
so let's start at the very beginning
here how much debt do you got brother
i got 21 565.
break that down for me i got it
the credit cards is it student loans
what is it
so i have 16 000 in an rv that i'm
living in
which i'm debating on selling and then
the rest is just personal line of credit
that i hold okay how much could you get
for the rv do you know
so i owe 16 and i probably could get
maybe around 12
to 14 for it and then where would you
live
uh i would probably random apartment yes
so i would sell that thing tomorrow yeah
unless here's the deal unless you are
i know a lot of roughnecks out there in
west texas that will go live in those
things on the
in the field and then come back and so
if that's what you have to do
right now then you can absolutely hit
the gas on paying that thing off
in in two months and three months and
i'm talking
don't go out to eat don't go do anything
cool and get that thing paid off
if you're not doing that if you're
actually working are you are you at
wells there in abilene are you out there
in midland
odessa i'm in big spring okay
man i would sell that thing tomorrow
yeah and even if you have to go get a
bridge loan for four grand if you're
making that kind of money though you
should have four thousand dollars you
can just go pay that thing off
and or pay the pay the balance on it and
then be done with it and then go get
yourself a one or two bedroom apartment
there in abilene texas
not a lot of money and don't take out
another
loan you were working so hard to clear
all this stuff you just sold a beautiful
40 000 truck
you are too far down the road man to
take any steps back
does your work go ahead my brother told
me he's like there is no such thing as
good
debt so i'm like well there is not you
know
i work a 10-4 schedule so on my four
days off i like to mow grass for extra
income
perfect i'm gonna my idea was to invest
in getting a trailer
and now that i don't have my truck i was
like well maybe i could give me like a
ten thousand dollar truck something
reliable so i can do that on the side
still
but i was also thinking like i'm so
close to getting out again
i could just give me a three thousand
four thousand dollar car civic
or something yes yes yes do you
do not borrow money first of all i know
he's your brother but you don't need to
take any more financial advice from your
brother
do you take romantic advice from your
brother i hope not
no okay well then you put financial
advice right underneath that okay you're
done with that
you can still love him give him a hard
time at thanksgiving but you're done
taking
money advice from him yeah okay okay and
so now
dude i spent a year shoving a mower and
a weed eater and a gas can and a blower
in the back of an 88 tercel hatchback
you can figure it out
until you can earn enough money to buy a
5 000 truck that will get you around
that big
the big country area listen so right now
i got a 15 year old kid it's gonna be 16
in november so i'm already starting to
look all right
i i have never been on facebook
marketplace in my life until three weeks
ago
okay it's a dark scary place man so
somebody told me about it and so i go on
i'm like wow this is amazing here's my
point
you can find a truck for three
four five grand easy that'll get you
where you need to an abilene
uh don't pay ten thousand for a truck
three four or five thousand or didn't
you have to be a truck get an
old uh suv or something you wouldn't
believe what's out there
i mean seriously i know and jacob i
lived in abilene texas
in i think it was 2009 or 10
when it didn't rain for a hundred
straight days
like a dust bowl it was a hundred
degrees every day and the lawn guys
were up a creek and so what you don't
want to do is have a ten thousand dollar
truck
and a new uh riding mower and all this
new top gear
and then have it roll over on you yeah
okay don't
yes sir borrow money you're so close man
yeah
you're so close give your little kid how
old is your little boy
he's 10 years old all right man y'all go
get an apartment
get out of an rv sell the rv go get into
an apartment
keep it's hard man because you're close
and now you want to start like i got a
scheme i got a thing you're a grinder
you're making six figures in the field
you work your butt off you're a hard
worker
don't skip steps man just keep taking
the small ones get rid of the trailer
i love the apartment idea get get one
with a pool so the the 10 year old can
flop around
you guys have a big time you can throw
them in the pool feels good for
everybody throw him in the pool i love
that that's exactly right all right
let's go out to chris in lexington hey
what's up chris
hey man how's it going good hey we're
getting up against the clock so jump
right into your question
all right so i'm 20 year old i got the
paid off double wide it's a hundred
thousand dollar double wide
and uh so i moved an hour and a half
away from college for college
and uh now i got a new job lined up that
whenever i graduate
the pay goes up a lot like 65 000.
okay and uh so
i have some family and friends tell me
that i should sell this stuff a lot
but if i sell the double light and get a
house
would it be better to move the double
wide whenever i graduate and get this
new job
or would it be better to sell the
double-eyed and then
go buy a house you pay the double wide
off correct
yeah but yeah the double watts paid off
okay well how much would a house be in
this area that you're going to have your
job
a house that you would how much
a lot more like
150 200 000 something like that because
the cost of living is insane
compared to our souls and that right now
you have to forgive me i know nothing
about double wise
here's another shockingly but it's
losing value every day that you
live in it right but it's also paid off
it's also paid off so my question is do
you have to buy a parcel of land
i'm assuming to to park said double wide
on i'm assuming that's the case
okay yeah so i i would have to buy like
you know any any kind of piece of
property
but the the cost to take the double wide
over there would probably be
around 8 000 and uh to set everything up
you know around
12 000 all together including the price
of the land
so probably like 30 000 35 000 something
like that so chris
here's what i'm doing if i'm you i would
sell that thing yeah i would take the
stupid tax loss you'll learn that you
learned a good lesson to not
buy homes with wheels on them and i
would go rent an apartment
and call it good go make a whole bunch
of money until i could put 10 to 20
down on a house exactly and i would i
would head that route yeah you don't
need to buy a house congrats on this
work
that you're getting as a result of
hustling i agree let's get out of the
double white it's cut our losses
and rent for a while it's not a sin to
rent no and you're gonna get a chunk of
money put that
money into a money market account and
just sit on it you don't need to
go bananas with it just hold it until
you got enough money till you find
a place in this new area where you're
going to live um
the housing market may correct itself it
may just keep on who knows man
we're making that up as we go but you
don't have to do anything now
you feel this pressure i got this new
job so i've got to do you don't you
don't let's go move in get a job get a
one-bedroom apartment yeah
live cheap man yeah you were on your own
wow
we you know we didn't ask i regret this
i wonder if he had a redwood deck on it
that's in a country song somewhere i
can't pull the song right now
maybe a sammy kershaw song you know what
i'm talking about you don't texas boy
you really don't know no you lost me at
red deck do you know who sammy kershaw
is i do not
wow james you're mr museum he quizzes me
on his show for music stuff and gives me
a hard time for not knowing so i have no
sympathy for him right now
that's awesome i think the most the most
stunning revelation from that last
caller was that you don't know anything
about trailer
at home look at that that was above my
pay grade
i was looking at james for some help
thought he might fire something away on
the screen like
i didn't know i assumed you had to have
land for it yeah you can't just
there's not like a rental spot or you
can't do that oh you can
yeah you can move it into it that's kind
of pricey though it can that's right
look at us all learning what would you
do if i bought a double wide i
would rent one of the rooms hey another
hour in the books good folks
thanks for joining us uh we'll be right
back on the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from their dollar
car
rental studio this is the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money and your work i'm john
dalone joined here with best-selling
author and
national sensation ken coleman oh wow
you're a sensation now by the way uh
james can we cut that and i'd like to
play that clip on my phone when i walk
into the house tonight to the three
teens
ladies and gentlemen national sensations
just so you'll know in fact i'd like
y'all to start calling me
not dad but national sensation national
association
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're taking your calls on life
on money on anything that's going on
we're here again how are you man well
i'll tell you what i
am uh living the dream man we we get to
do what we love we get to help people
and and we get to do it with
fun people and uh we're having a blast
today you and i we always have a good
time i like it
uh james is in a good mood uh so that's
always good you know james childs
everybody knows his name but they don't
understand he can be he can be really
tough quiet guy very tough today
he's smiling wonderful person he's a
wonderful man wonderful man so
everybody's in a good mood we're here
for you folks we're excited
and uh we've had a good show good show
yes and so we're taking your calls
triple eight eight two five
two anything you got going on in your
life give us a shout
life work purpose relationships money
we're here triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go out to boston
and talk to
frank what's up frank how we doing man
good how you doing outstanding what's up
how can we help
i'm i'm trying to figure out what to do
i'm 60 and i'm i'm burned out of the
40-hour work week i i want to cut down
and i don't know you know i'm trying to
find something that's less
hours right now i have a job and i'm
trying to work with them to
to go on four day work week but it might
be tough i'm not sure and i have a bad
commute
but i was thinking of doing it one more
year and just
quitting and taking a year off and
figuring out what i want to do
i want to keep working but less yeah
that's great
yeah well frank that's really good news
i'm assuming here that
that this idea of taking a year off and
figuring out what you want to do means
that you're in a good financial
situation that you're not
debt and that you don't have any kind of
financial pressure is that is that a
correct assumption
yes that's great i listen we don't need
to take a year
i think we take the next four or five
minutes and figure it out because i just
believe a guy like you
who's 60 years old who's at a place of
being burned out
i just know that your brain and your
heart have been throwing
signals up and they may have actually
connected but you're not quite sure
how to get there maybe you've got some
fear maybe you've got some doubt i just
don't believe you called today
with zero ideas of what you would do am
i right frank
you're right i knew it aaron so frank
let's just be real all right frank from
boston
no nonsense man throw it out there what
would you do tomorrow
if you knew you couldn't fail and it was
going to be the hours that you wanted
in the twilight of your work career what
would you do frank i know you thought
about it
what would you do i think i would um
well up in maine they have those um
those
three-day uh flea markets i think i
would sell junk
i would i love i love doing that i love
setting up
dude you're stunned frank frank i got to
tell you something
you never want to stereotype anybody but
that's in the range of what i thought
you might say
i didn't you no you didn't think so i
thought he was going to say you know
what
no he likes stuff i want to i want to
open up an orphanage i thought it was
going to be
really yeah frank you just became a hero
of mine he loves junk frank why do you
love junk
i like i like vintage electronics i work
in high tech
and i'm just i'm burned out of high tech
but i like it as a hobby
yeah you love the idea of fixing stuff
up that still has some value
right that and um i'm not sure how much
money i could really make
but you know i've also thought about
this
actually amusement park there i would do
that part time i'd do a few
few different things listen i could love
this frank listen to me
frank what's keeping you from doing that
my my family is kind of
you know i have to move away i'd be
alone i'd be isolated
i'm going to be far away and that's the
problem right now my job's like a cash
cow
and i'd like to you know keep to stay
there for as long as i can and then
all right so hold on hold on let's
address that issue okay because i think
that is the big thing by the way i
respect that i think that's a legitimate
hurdle
but i think that that takes into account
an assumption that's false
and that assumption is is that maine
that particular part of maine which i
think you really like
is the only place that you can do that
type of work in this twilight
he could do that stuff in boston i mean
boston if you're in the greater boston
metropolitan area
uh there's got to be some theme parks
around there there's got to be
plenty of uh flea markets and stuff like
that in areas where you can do that kind
of
that kind of work true or false it's
true it's seasonal though so i'd have to
you know do something in the winter also
yeah but frank
all the difference indoor ones too yeah
man
and the other side of that is at what
point are you gonna put your oxygen mask
on first
what was that well at some point you got
to put on your oxygen mask man
or your or this burnout is going to
you're going to slowly drown
and the story you will have told
yourself as you go underwater is
man look what i did for everybody else
well here's the deal frank you're
already burned out
your word your word's not mine so john's
absolutely right what he means if i put
you on a mascot you know on the airplane
instructions they say if
the cabin loses oxygen the mass drop
from the ceiling they always tell you to
put yours on first
so i understand you want to be in your
family but you know how far away from
family would you be
uh a couple of hours
not really really not that far but they
they i
you know my family 20 minutes is a long
time
well but wait a second wait a second
john's on to something that sounds like
a them
problem brother sounds like you're using
your family as an excuse to not go do
what you want to do
you're totally using your family's
excuse you're scared big old tough frank
come on frank from boston yeah he's
scared
who are you worried about who's this
family is it sisters brothers what is it
yeah all of them and brother sister
my mother's getting old so again frank
two hours man that's a grocery store run
the way you drive that's 90 minutes come
on frank i know you drive fast two to
four
two to four hours or something like that
hey dude you gotta live your life
gotta live your life i know hey but the
real thing behind this frank underneath
all this it
if your family only wants you around for
your money
they're taking your soul from you okay
and if you work like crazy so that
other people your brothers and sisters
will be quote unquote proud of you or
you're the one who did it
man you're living a fake false life i'd
go to maine
and uh frank i'd get an awesome little
cabin and tell the brothers and sisters
to throw mama in the car
two weekends out of the month and let's
have a let's have some lobster
that's right they can drive clean free
hey you worked really hard to put
yourself in this position
go enjoy your life frank go sell
junk that just sounds awesome it's
awesome frank do what you want to do
you've earned it you're 60 man
life is short get after it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
are you tired of feeling stuck with your
money
like you'll never get out of debt or
save enough for the future
listen it doesn't have to be that way
you can make progress with your money
and faster than you think but the only
way to make it happen is with
a budget that's why you need a ramsey
plus
membership you'll get access to the
premium version of our every dollar
budgeting app
where you'll plan out every dollar
you'll spend and save before the month
begins
connect your budget to your bank so you
never miss a transaction
get custom budget reports that show you
where you can find more money to put
towards your goals
when you budget and get intentional with
your money you will
make progress fast and you can start
budgeting
for free today text trial
to 33789 for a free trial of ramsay plus
that's trial to 33789
all right let's go out to los angeles
california and talk to
alex hey alex what's going on hello
hey what's up hey um
how's it going uh good what's up thank
you
oh okay well uh so yeah um
i have a situation here at home uh
i'm living at home i uh i live with my
mother and her boyfriend and um
i'm having problems with them at home
it's not a good situation
i've been having fights with them and
how old are you they're not really tough
i'm 29 oh yeah move out
yesterday yes
that's what i was why are you still
living there
well because i was living in washington
i was
uh living on my own but uh things happen
um
we don't do vegan cryptic on this show
what things happen there's a reason why
you're living there why are you living
there
well because i i didn't i was i didn't
do well in washington i made a lot of
mistakes and i had to move out
from my apartment they were evicting me
and so i came back
and i had problems with my father that i
was living with him for a while
and then i came with my mother because
when kovit hit
i i uh they kicked me out so so hold on
hold on
hold on so you're living there because
financially you can't live on your own
i i suppose i can but it would be with
like in a room
or like a garage converted
okay alex you have do you have addiction
issues
no okay so there's something that
is following you around that happens to
be you
what are you bringing to all these
situations that are making it hard for
people to live with you
i don't know i suppose it just
alex people have told you man okay so
you get you get angry you get frustrated
i get upset with them yeah okay
have you ever sat down and talked to
somebody about it before
not really i never thought that it was
something that
i wanted to or i should have needed to
do
so what i would tell you is just if you
step back
and look at the data that life has
presented you
will tell you that getting angry getting
frustrated
results in for whatever reason your
response to different situations whether
it's in washington whether it's with
your dad
now it's with your mom and her boyfriend
you are the common denominator there
and i'm not going to beat you up for
that but i want you to say
i can continue to go to place to place
to place and be the common denominator
or
i have reached a point where i need to
go talk to somebody preferably
preferably a professional to get some
insight into
what tools am i not bringing to these
situations or
what am i contributing to my continued
inability to get along with other people
that we live with
right so that's not why you called but i
do think
you are worth getting to the bottom of
those questions yeah okay
but get out get out what's keeping you
from getting out is it a good paying job
is it the fact that you could live in a
converted garage or a one-room
deal with somebody else and you just
don't want that or you can move to
kansas
and rent a three-bedroom apartment like
what why are you stuck there
yeah well i guess because
i want to say it's my home um
you know my family is
a immigrant origin family yeah
um ever since i could remember
like literally ever since i remember it
was from one house to another from that
house to another
from one apartment to another and we
finally landed here
and and it sucks because you know this
is where i have
a lot of my memory since i was 11
years old and i i don't know it's hard
for me because i'm gonna miss it
you know this is where i've had a lot of
her memory yeah
i get that and i i don't want to in any
way to minimize that
but you called us saying hey i i'm 29
years old i'm living with my mom and her
boyfriend and we're fighting and i want
to get out and we're telling you get out
and the way to get out is one we've got
to have the financial means to do so
i think you have the financial means to
get out i understand it's going to hurt
but you can come back and visit
and i would suggest to you that if you
take john's advice
and you begin to get some help and get
healthy we can visit we can come back
and we can still uh uh hang out in that
house
and have a better relationship with mom
in a place of wonderful memories
but you're 29 you need to live your own
life and so it's time to move on
and i understand it's not going to be
perfect a converted garage or whatever i
understand
but here's the deal it's progress and if
you if you decide to move out
and you go this is just a stepping stone
for me and and i'm going to take that
that desire to not be a tumbleweed as my
life is presented to me i've had to move
from place to place to place that's made
me feel very unstable and all the things
all that stuff i mean my heart breaks
for you on that and i think that's real
but you can decide to say i'm going to
change the pattern
it stops with me but it starts by me
getting out of the house
getting healthy and creating my own path
how does that sound alex that sounds
great that's really what i want to do i
really want to uh
you can't become not only just
financially but in life stable
yeah i do want to i do want to enjoy
life
in all aspects good for you i do have i
do have
more than just one goal yes and
i i can't do it in this in this uh
this in this space in this situation
love it's a very negative
that's right this is very negative
that's right
my question was though is that uh i do
want to learn a trade
because i think with learning a trade i
don't know if i'm wrong or right
but i i i have better means
of uh financial um absolutely right
alex what trade are you most interested
in
well i was thinking in carpentry
fantastic are you talented with your
hands so you've always been
kind of even if it's a rough i mean if
it's it's an undeveloped skill
but you're pretty good at building
things fixing things putting things
together you got that talent yes or no
i like doing that i didn't ask you if
you liked it i said do you have some
talent at it i mean let me tell you
you're good at it i'm a guy who can
barely hammer a nail all right this is
full confession here i'm i'm a disaster
no talent my brother guy could build
stuff out of a piling
yeah he's unbelievable uh do you have a
talent alex can you build stuff do you
have that
construction that carpentry type talent
alex yeah uh i guess not
i don't know what do you mean you don't
no you do know
if i talk to people who know you would
they say alex has always been pretty
good at his hands he was just always
natural knows how to use a saw he can
fix a little thing he can do some trim
come on
yes or no do you have the raw talent yes
or no
yeah all right then there we go then
pursue that trade that's all i wanted to
know it wasn't a trick question i just
want to make sure you're not delusional
well make sure you've got that talent
because you've got the raw talent john i
can develop the skill hey listen
go sign up for trade school here's the
thing why don't you drive around a
couple construction sites in la and walk
up and go hey
my name is alex i'm here to work i've
held down a great job this is who i
am i'm responsible i got my driver's
license i want to learn the trade i'll
start doing anything i'll just start
shooting
three-quarter inch plywood up to the
second floor i'll be a labor that's what
i did
john in one of my sophomore one of my my
sophomore summer in college
they need laborers get in get on the
work site and the next thing you know
they're going to hand you a hammer
they're going to teach you how to do it
they're going to teach you how to do it
come on alex
take control of your future man and
listen alex
when you are a part of an immigrant
family when you move from house to house
to house to house to house
that being untethered that frustration
that anger and you're not by yourself go
see somebody yeah
go talk to somebody and say hey i need
to learn some skills okay
you're worth it your family's worth it
and your future legacy
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show give us a call
at 825-5225
i'm john deloney joined here with ken
coleman and we're taking your calls on
pretty much everything
life relationships work purpose money
all of it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to tina in
atlanta what's up tina how are you doing
i'm sorry i'm keen on oh tina sorry
about that brother yes
thank you thank you tina for taking my
call you got it brother what's up
thanks ken and dr delany for doing all
that you do i we really appreciate it um
thank you so much so what's up man yeah
sure um so i've been working for this
company for about um
12 years okay um i am in a medical field
um so been working with my supervisor
for the past 10 years
and our relationship grew uh as a
co-worker
now he's my supervisor and
we've been working well in the beginning
however as time went by
as recently as about a year ago um
the organization has grew and the
responsibilities for me
has grown as well and my supervisor
basically started to really
just started to really disrespect me um
although
my skill level has gone up in fact i am
one of the few
employees there who understand and knows
the system inside and out and all the
things that
we do there so i'm having to teach
junior
personnel and as well as um involved in
a lot of decision-making process however
a constant undermining from my
supervisor as well as
disrespecting it's gotten to a point
where i'm considering going
uh part-time okay because instead of
arguing
i'm trying to change the person i don't
believe the person will change
i was thinking about going part-time so
i can gain
some of my sanity back multiple times i
spoke with him about his behaviors and
he acknowledged it
uh and he said he would change uh in his
own ways
but i just don't know whether he will no
he's not
he's not going to yes no chance and and
you're you're absolutely right
uh teen on to say hey uh
this is a problem you've done everything
that i would ask you to do you answered
all my questions
except for why are you considering going
part time instead of just leaving all
together
explain what's behind that thought
so uh what i'm promised recently is that
um promise for promotion
in the department and also um
by who who promised you a promotion um
well
he has um our timeout
come on man i mean really i can't even
believe you just i can't believe you
just threw that at me
let me let me ask you do you think he's
going to promote you
no i question that all right so let's
not let's not waste any more time
i'll answer that you question it i'll
answer it no no he's not going to
so again why part-time as opposed to
just saying
the season is over i've got a lot of
talent
i've got a lot of experience and i'm out
[Music]
that was john john is a wonderful
singing voice uh why
why part-time why right um
so financially we're pretty secure wife
and i we do pretty well the money is not
an issue in fact
we followed ramsey steps and we are now
completely deaf free accept
you're avoiding my question why is
part-time an option why not just leave
you're answering a purpose question with
a dollar amount yeah
gotcha um i enjoy people there i
enjoy my doctors that i work with great
um
and it's not it's a great place except
this immediate supervisor has been the
it's pretty uh pretty heavy weight on my
career
is there a um
you've done the right thing ethically
which is to go to the person that you're
struggling with and say here's what i'm
struggling with about you
and they've they've acknowledged i'm
failing you and i will do better and
then they have repeatedly not done
better
is there another person to then go to
well there's a supervisor above him
which i believe is just is going to be a
new point because that supervisor is
going to be
relying on him to manage the department
that
my immediate supervisor is in charge of
yeah so
it doesn't seem like there's a fix so
here's what this boils down to
and i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
be unkind i'm not trying to
paint you in a corner but brother you
have two options
you either put up with this and it's
going to eventually eat away at you and
suck your soul out of your body and i
would suggest that it's starting to
which is why you called today
or you walk away but the part-time
option isn't an
option that's just delaying the
inevitable so you have two
options so here's the deal if you want
to be eventually miserable there
then keep doing what you're doing and
then do the part-time version because
all it's going to mean is you're
part-time miserable
but you have to choose i understand
you've got relationships there i get
that you're a wonderful dude you got a
great heart it's obvious
but all those kind people and all the
nice things in the world
isn't going to change the fact of what i
just said
and it's going to happen you will resent
you'll get miserable and then you're
going to leave and then you're going to
be
unhealthy i think right now you're kind
of starting to see
and you've put up with it for a year how
much longer you want to put up with it
how much i know i'm right so what are
you going to do
you're scared you're terrified as it is
well
starting in any new organization is just
it's it's just that
yeah no one wants that okay so here's
the stressful thing
well yeah yeah it is except for the fact
that
you're you're right now you're basically
saying to me ken i think i'd rather be
miserable than uncomfortable i'd rather
take half of my salary and go part-time
instead of making 50 grand or 100 grand
or other just make half
tina listen to me you just said i'd
rather be miserable
than uncomfortable does that make any
sense to you
you're right i'm turning you over to my
colleague who's the professional
psychologist
now that i've diagnosed it i'm not able
to fix it
other than what i told you to do you
need to leave and you're very qualified
i'm sorry i'm preaching
20 more seconds tina listen to me you're
qualified man
you're good at what you do you've got a
tremendous amount of value
you live in atlanta georgia one of the
top metropolitan
areas in the united states a little bit
of uncomfortableness
is just part of growth but you better
choose
growth or misery
those are your choices what are you
gonna choose man
yeah well my wife thinks that i am
thinking about all the excuses stay
because i'm afraid of making changes
that's what i just said yeah
get your wife on the phone can we patch
her in please she's at work
yeah i know she's right by the way your
wife is right your wife is
almost always one thing that i want to
tell you guys so you can have an insight
on this i know i'm taking a lot of time
but
basically um my supervisor uh his role i
mean he
he basically had moved up
in organization because of the work that
i've done for him
things were built on my back so to speak
and i know that and he knows that
that's why he had pulled me away from
different departments
every time he moved up he brought me in
i know but listen i realized that i was
the guy who was making the
things a lot easier for him okay okay so
here's what we're gonna give you
i'm gonna give you a um small to
medium-sized golf clap
congratulations you're an incredible
worker
you are brilliant you are valued by an
organization
this guy doesn't even respect you or
like you and he's still gonna promote
you because he knows how good you are
and you don't believe
in your own value you let a guy that is
running over you and stealing from you
intellectually
and spiritually dictate your life
your wife is sick of it ken coleman
talked to you for four minutes and he's
the career expert oh by the way i'm sick
of it
he can't even breathe yeah yeah it took
four it took two minutes for me to get
sick of it
he said listen you're allowing yourself
to be abused that's exactly right
you are worth more than this yeah here's
what i want you to do i want you to sit
down with your wife tonight
tonight and i want you to say honey i'm
done and now we're going to start
painting a new picture of what
tomorrow's going to look like
and then let her speak into it cause
she's been dying to speak into it for a
long long time
and then you're gonna be about this
weekend next weekend you're gonna be
about
making your move because it's time and
yes it's gonna be stressful
then you're gonna find peace that you
haven't had years and years you got this
tinon
you got this got it solving problems on
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture is psalm 37 23-24
the lord makes firm the steps of the one
who delights in him
though he may stumble he will not fall
for the lord upholds him with his hand
jim rohn says if you are not willing to
risk the usual
you will have to settle for the ordinary
if you are not willing to risk the usual
you'll have to settle
for the ordinary way to go jim all right
let's go
to lawrence in tacoma washington hey
lawrence what's going on
hey guys how are you guys doing
outstanding how are you man
pretty good hey i just uh i want to say
thanks for the for what you guys both do
uh john i was listening to your podcast
and i appreciate all your sound effects
thank you i i'm looking at james right
now who clearly does not
and i need you to know lawrence you made
my day and i appreciate it
heavy heavy point of tension there
between those guys and you just made it
more tense so that's great
nope you just you just you just uh moved
the
the teeter-totter a little bit in my way
so thank you
got you some more points that's good so
what's up man okay so uh
yeah so my question is just to give a
little context i was actually listening
to
you guys on tuesday i think this canon
day that we're on and
we're talking about how hot like the
market is for
used cars so
uh we owe about 14 500
on my wife's car and so
i was thinking like oh okay well i heard
you guys say that so i reached out to
um to the person that we the dealership
that we bought the car from
said of an appointment that i actually
have in about 20 minutes or so for an
appraisal
but what they're saying is that they
could potentially buy the car back for
what we paid for
which was about 21 about 21 000
and i'm hoping that if they buy it back
for
at least 20 that i could use that amount
to uh purchase a minivan because they're
looking at getting a minivan
and uh and maybe have a small amount
of debt after that instead of the 14-5
i'm just wondering if that you think
that's a good idea
um ken i wasn't on that hour my first
inclination is when a dealer says i'll
pay you this for something they already
have a markup
in mind which tells me you would make
more money on the private market but i
wasn't on that segment
yeah well that's well the bottom line is
is that right now
dealers are paying premium money for
used cars
because there's so much demand uh but
john's absolutely right
so uh lawrence what i would do is i
would go do kelly blue book uh and and
be really really honest and you can kind
of get a sense for what that private
sale would look like
to johnson okay good what did you see
what
about 1905 i think great i'd hold on to
that number
listen that's great so we got 19.5 in
our pocket if you sell it yourself
all right and uh well let's see what the
dealer says
because if the dealer says 20 or 21 i'm
selling to the dealer
now like instantly i'll uber home but
yeah yeah
that's absolutely right uh because you
don't know what you're gonna get in the
private market the dealer offers you 20.
i'd take it so fast their head would
spin
i mean i really would or ask them if
they'll trade you a a
minivan straight up and then here's what
well but here's what i was going to
challenge you on you're not going to
like this
okay i'm going to show you a minivan
straight up
that was my dumb and dumber i don't know
i don't know if i like that strategy
take the money because you're gonna pay
off the car right your debt your the
debt's gone
and you're gonna have let's say they
offer you 20 you're going to have five
and a half left
i try to find an older minivan i i would
try to pay the whole thing off and i'd
try to find a
5 000 minivan that'll work for six
months or a year
and then save up uh i i wouldn't i'd
knock the whole debt out if it were me
that's exactly what i would do i
wouldn't i wouldn't pay partial i'd
knock the whole thing
out did i hear you right that's the only
debt you have left
um we have uh her student loan that's
it's gonna be i think after some
payments that we need that snowball this
month will be under
000 so we're pretty close and so that's
why i was really excited about it
dude listen to me listen to me listen to
me close to being jeffrey cleared all
out man if we had enough time left on
the air
i would i would stay on the line we
would do the first time ever we'd have
the dealer come on and we'd accept the
deal for you
yes that's what i would do i would take
the deal yes take the deal
and and listen go find something that's
affordable for five thousand
i mean not affordable that's functional
for five thousand bl and i'm telling you
can find it
yes and then be done with it man be debt
free be done with it knock the student
loan out
and now we can we can just pile away at
that emergency fund and then we're
buying a nice minivan
in six to 10 12 months max yes
or two years no one's gonna die you're
gonna be all right that is true you know
what i mean
all right let's take one more call let's
go to nick in medford hey nick what's
going on man we're right up against the
clock so
uh what's your question hey
dr d and ken how are you guys doing
outstanding man what's up
so i'm in the i'm in the counseling
profession
and i love what i do it's i'm passionate
about my line of work
but i hear often how this line of work
does not make a lot of money
and i feel i'm really grateful at the
position i'm in right now but i'm
also looking ahead and i'm curious as to
what
what people do i need to be around or
what are some steps i can take to make
anywhere between
100 to 150 000 i remember in grad school
they had a private practitioner come in
that was doing really well
and everyone was talking kumbaya stuff
and how you can help people and i agree
with all that
but i raised my hand and i was in a
community and i said i i just i don't
want to be crass but
how do i make six figures as a counselor
in this community
and he said you're not gonna like my
answer i said well what is it
and he said be really really good at
counseling
and work really really hard develop a
good reputation
and so here's what i would do i have
personally
called and met with taking a coffee
taken to lunch people who
own their own practice they multiple
therapists work for them
i've got a cup a friend who's um it's a
husband-and-wife team
in texas and they have multiple
therapists that work for them multiple
interns that work for them they pay them
really well
and i know people who do consulting with
businesses on the side who have a
practice and also are professors
there's a hundred different ways to go
about it but it's about you it's it's
it's ken's proximity principle it's
about you reaching out to
any and everybody in medford oregon that
will possibly go to coffee with you
and ask them every question you got but
at the end of the day right now
counselors are doing remarkably well
in certain areas of course because they
can put their practice online they can
meet with people now
at six in the morning at six at night
they can meet the clients
in different places and locations cash
pay is rule in the day so
there's a a hundred different options
here really it's you figuring out what
you want to do what you're good at
another great way to make money as a
therapist is running groups because
everybody can bring a little bit less
money in
you can help out more people in your
community but you make more money per
hour
so there's a bunch of different options
there does any of those sound right to
you
yeah no thank you so much yeah nick
listen
we're going to give you a copy of my
book the proximity principle which
literally is
it's chapter by chapter it's going to
walk you through what john
just said who you're connecting with
what you're asking
you just got to learn to be a human
sponge
and say hey i want to learn this here's
why i want to learn it i think you can
help me
people find tremendous value in that
when you value their advice
so don't be intimidated by this john's
absolutely right and beyond just getting
the advice
you you're going to clarify and verify
some things you're going to clarify
all the different paths like john just
said this group therapy i mean you could
run two or three of those a night
that's right you get 10 dudes in a room
you start doing the numbers on that i
mean
and again john's absolutely right here
and i and i'm not the counselor but i
tell you this
the people that are really really good
at what they do
people walk out of those counseling
sessions and they go you gotta go see
this guy
you got to go see this gal and he was
expensive and she was expensive
she rocked my world she changed my life
and so that's how their rates get up
there
so and i'm just making these up as round
numbers but if you're charging a hundred
dollars an hour right now
the only way you're going to get to 200
an hour or 300 an hour is unbelievable
results so it is that your mentor that
was a great answer you're not gonna like
it because this is hard work
this is not just hard work excellent
work you gotta dig you gotta take people
to a place of health you gotta be really
good at it
and here's the thing about working in
mental health you may realize
i don't wanna to do that do i don't
wanna do what it takes to make that kind
of money in this profession because it's
hard right good point
hey i want to thank james childs and
kelly daniel for another great show
i love you guys y'all are great i love
you too man
ken i love you guys it's always fun i
love you too appreciate you guys
everybody engineers too thank you all be
kind to one another respect each other
and we'll see you soon
this has been the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
you